unas 25.000 personas se reunieron por la
llamada marcha de las banderas sabes
punto culmine del día de jerusalén
cuando los israelíes se celebran la
reunificación de la ciudad tras la
guerra de los seis días de 1967 pero que
los palestinos viven con temor y repudio
por la ocupación de la parte este esta
controvertida marcha que hace un año
desembocó en una guerra entre israel y
hamas reunió a 13 nacionalistas
religiosos desde la puerta de damasco
hasta el muro de las lamentaciones
atravesando el barrio musulmán para
permitir el desfile la policía obligó a
los comerciantes palestinos a cerrar y
desde temprano realizó decenas de
detenciones a su paso varios
manifestantes se entonaron consignas
como muerte a los árabes y mahoma está
muerto las escenas de violencia marcaron
la jornada incluso antes de la
movilización con hechos como la quema de
una bandera palestina o la agresión de
un joven israelí con gas pimienta a una
mujer palestina la media luna roja
reportó decenas de heridos en respuesta
a hubo movilizaciones en hebrón ramala y
hasta en jerusalén este esta última
reprimida por las fuerzas de seguridad
previamente un récord de dos mil 600
judíos escoltados por las fuerzas
israelíes ingresaron en la explanada de
las mezquitas durante la mañana algunos
de ellos con banderas israelíes y
entonando cantos y oraciones al vulnera
el statu quo de este espacio reservado
para el culto musulmán algunos
palestinos se habían convocado en la
mezquita de al-aqsa y arrojaron piedras
fuegos artificiales entonaron cánticos y
elevaron banderas palestinas varios
resultaron agredidos y la policía
israelí detuvo al menos 18 personas
tanto la autoridad palestina como
jordania que custodian la explanada de
las mezquitas cuestionaron a israel por
permitir el ingreso de los extremistas y
pidieron el cese de la violencia en al
aqsa